they call them see des large properties
subdivided into small quarters where one
or more families live cramped together
often sharing a bathroom with up to a
dozen other families they're the only
option for many Haitian migrants in
Chile like Jean Sanofi the kitchen
doesn't work the bathroom too but it's
difficult for us to rent here and hiding
my children each have their own room I
would never bring them here
Chile has the largest Haitian migrant
community outside of the United States
and it's public knowledge that they're
exploited by unscrupulous landlords and
now with the corona virus pandemic
they're being discriminated further a
few weeks ago this seat day with 88
rooms became nationwide news health
authorities moved the haitian residents
to a special quarantine area with better
facilities but first the results of
their Perona virus tests were published
on the municipalities web page violating
a patient's right to confidentiality the
news spread like wildfire
even before the cameras arrived the
neighbors began throwing rocks and
hurling insults at the Haitians because
a few of them had been confirmed to be
carrying coronavirus now they tell us
that they feel even more discriminated
and vulnerable than ever the fear of the
virus has only increased the
stigmatization of Haitians since Ralph
Jon batiste who works as a community
translator the area of 50s the community
is very angry and upset if they'd been
from Europe from Germany this would not
have happened
Ralph is always dressed impeccably
because he says it helps to counter a
constant disrespect of blacks by
Chileans the reason for that negative
these people say get out you Blacky
there is cruel discrimination here that
we can't ignore it's made worse because
many Haitian migrants don't speak
Spanish and don't know their rights the
condition of regard with very precarious
living conditions it's even more
difficult for them to survive in a
pandemic the charged extortionate rents
many can't afford the virus doesn't
discriminate but we do the governor of
Santiago's metropolitan region agrees
that many migrants are living in
inhumane conditions but when we asked
why authorities haven't stopped
landlords from renting unsanitary and
overcrowded living quarters he blamed
the mayor's
the truth is that authorities have
constantly turned a blind eye to a
sanitary and human rights dilemma that
is punishing those who came here for a
better life as never before you see in
human al Jazeera Santi ro